phil said why do women like drama having
an emotional rollercoaster
what's the evolutionary benefit or is
this just a byproduct of solipsism
and being the star of a real life movie
i think this is manufactured indignation
rollo this is your wheelhouse
well i think uh i honestly i think there
is an evolutionary
need for it anyways um i think right now
as i said before like how do you make a
woman miserable you give her everything
that she's ever wanted now
that's like on a personal level now
think of that on a meta scale
like in a gynocentric social order where
we give women more and more
and more convenience dishwashers washing
machines
you know women's rights right to vote
this that and
i'm not saying you shouldn't have those
things i'm just saying that we
make it easier it's like men especially
for beta men
for throughout history their way to sort
of solve their
their reproductive problem has always
been to make life as easy as possible
for women because they believe in the
chore play narrative
in it writ large right the the easier i
can make a woman's life the more time
she'll have to bang me
which is like completely opposite but
what happens is like the reason why
women need that drama
there's two reasons the first one is
like we've made it too easy for them
and so they're craving that that innate
need for that the other thing is is that
it's part of women's existential fear so
when you watch like
shows that are like indignation
generating um
like say for instance the bachelor or
the bachelorette
the reason why that show has been around
for 25
years is its professional wrestling for
women is what it is
it's like it's like they need that that
kind of high or that that thrill but
you're like well why do they need that
well the reason is is they want to know
that that hypergamous filter is still
functioning
so when people when women talk about
like their um their
was it their the feminine mystique right
their women's intuition
they want to know that that it still
works so
when you see a show like cheaters or
something like that
that like really stimulates that
indignation or the bachelorette or the
bachelor or whatever
yeah yeah exactly um uh 50 shades of
grey um
name the name the thing that the genre
or whatever that women really love and i
will guarantee i will show you every
time
it stimulates that indignation need
because that indignation need is tied
to her ability to filter out the fakes
from the real thing and when we say no
no no we're the real thing and these are
the fakes and when you when you make
that decision for them
it's like they have to manufacture for
themselves they like the chemical rush
that comes from indignation
because they want to be able to say ha
this guy is actually a cheater i found
him out
and even like vicariously through other
chicks
that's when they they still love it they
still get off on it because it
stimulates the same thing
so they want to know that they can still
they still got it right they can still i
can figure this guy out with my
intuition
and so that's why indignation is such a
big deal to them
by the way you want to stay away from
women that like consume that stuff
endlessly you know the national enquirer
the [ __ ] bachelor of the bachelorette
they will always love drama but it's
when it's like this constant like
addiction
need that it becomes well i don't think
you should filter like filter for it
like that
i think it's it's endemic if a girl is
getting excitement in her life
she doesn't go out looking for it it's
like her drug dealer nobody who has a
healthy sex life is addicted to porn
it's the same kind of thing so i would
argue if you see a girl who's hooked on
this stuff
that's her screaming at the world that
she's bored
and we always joke like what's the thing
about game right strong
or positive emotions negative emotions
doesn't matter as long as it's strong
so if anything it's almost like a girl
walking out with like a skirt that's two
inches too high it's just like a big
indication that she's
bored and if you're more entertaining
entertaining than 80 percent of guys out
there which is super easy
then you basically got yourself like a
kept tiger now hopefully she's of uh
she's aesthetically pleasing you don't
want to do this with a girl you're just
not into anyway
but not necessarily and then in a
marriage too if you see a girl is all of
a sudden hooked on serial killer dramas
well then maybe
maybe you just uh sitting there betting
on dog coin every day
isn't the most exciting life ever and
you can kind of step it up but i don't
know building your value
high status guys
you